[Music]
this
[Music]
well brandon another day
another dog
hi punky hi cherry
gary
chair
jerry you ain't that fed butt
[Laughter]
carrie mrs johnson stop yelling
you're not only waking the dead you're
making them glad they're dead
and it might be somebody in that
apartment i thought i heard a noise in
there yesterday
it's vacant well somebody could have
broke in you know
a [ __ ] escape convict
or sex maniac
just waiting to grab a voluptuous woman
you're know what safe
you're my idol i am
yeah just think you got your own
apartment you can step sleighs you want
and you don't have to go to school
you're the youngest girl to find out
thanks jerry
but you've got something at home what
family just my grandma
and she snores like a buzz sock
and nothing that dry downstairs is still
busted
do you not have to hang a clothesline
from my window
over to the telephone pole and the local
hoodlums been spray painting their
initials
on my underwear you could spray paint a
novel and you're on the way
all right all right i'll get the dryer
fixed
jerry
[Music]
[Music]
she's a maniac maniac um
who are you i'm punky brewster
and who are you i'm the manager of this
building henry warnimont
nice to meet you hank
i am not a hank i am a
henry
what are you doing here my husband and i
are looking
for an apartment
okay cut the character stop it's only
fair a warning
that this is an attack dog if you get
near me
he'll chew you to pieces
[Applause]
give me a break that dog couldn't chew
soup
now let's get back to you did you run
away from home don't climb up on me
young lady answer the question you'll
never make me say
anything i don't want to even shut my
head and knock out
and make me eat lime up beans
you're hungry depends on what why asking
i'm just asking how come i'm curious how
come cause i am how come
[Laughter]
look i'm going to fix myself some dinner
you can join me if you want to
you